[Musique]
pour faire enfin de l'élection vous avez
vous décidé de l'avenir pour vous même
pour vos enfants
notre à 1984 vous savez je me suis
engagé aux côtés de jacques chirac avec
l'espoir d'un vrai changement sept ans
plus tard après cinq années de
cohabitation stériles un peu tant de
temps perdu
je vous prie de choisir les fournisseurs
les rires du mode et de la france à
gauche celle que je défends avec
conviction le bol l'europe avance la
société française est plein d'énergie et
de vitalité et la politique française
piétine oui il faut se tenir ensemble
cette élection présidentielle pour faire
bouger la politique pour construire une
nouvelle france les fermes et
profondément l'état afin qu'ils exercent
sans complexe ses émissions la sécurité
la justice à laquelle je veux vous
donner les moyens de faire respecter la
nouvelle france compétitive qu'il fasse
reculer lé chômage
je veux faciliter la vie de celles et
ceux qui entreprennent et nuisent et sur
les petites et moyennes entreprises des
professions indépendantes et libérales
les agriculteurs les commerçants les
artisans
et créent de presse emploi à lahmada
s'engage à alléger le droit du travail
et toutes les réglementations qui
prennent la création d'emplois a offert
un contrat informations et pour chaque
jeune nagasu à plusieurs reprises à
libérer le travail pour sortir du carcan
des 35 heures obligatoires tout l'été
les partenaires sociaux il est libre
dans le travail dans l'entreprise pour
travailler plus travailler moins
travailler différemment pour trouver une
administration ou verts très
perfectionniste il faut cibler sur des
millions de français qui voudraient
créer aux entreprises se mettre à leur
compte ils sont autant de chances de
créer des emplois et je veux rendre
possible à la madeleine st gall et
l'homme est un programme choc en faveur
de la création d'entreprise pour créer
des millions de nouvelles entreprises
raconte favorisées puisque allant
d'investissement de régulation et des
besoins de l'entreprise créer un statut
social simplifier et alléger adapté à la
création de la petite entreprise et
facilitant l'embauchent du premier
salarié
chaque français doivent recevoir la
juste récompense de son travail ne se
mérite et de trôner et baisser les
impôts c'est le meilleur moyen de steam
de doper la croissance la création
d'emplois à la madeleine s'engage à
simplifier alléger la pension leur
homonymie intégrant la ccl amel n'ouvre
de 3 à 3 et tout petit peu ma 31%
pratiqué à supprimer l'impôt sur les
successions pour les petits les moyens
patrimoine appliquée déjà deauville
pour les activités à forte main d'oeuvre
mais c'est les un peu tout le monde ou
presque pas vous en parler
vous ne les voyez pas car pour baisser
vraiment les impôts il faut dans le même
temps baissé les dépenses publiques
comme l'ont fait nos partenaires
européens comme je m'y engage
et il faut avoir pour cela le courage de
réformer en font profondément d'état à
la mode là s'engage à réduire le poids
de la fonction publique en profitant du
départ matinée octobre à la retraite
mieux évaluer l'action publique et
réorganiser les missions de l'état
faire participer intéresser une
fonctionnaire à la récente de l'état
alléger fortement aux lois et aux
règlements pour simplifier la vie des
français si vous pensez que le moment
est venu de faire enfin bouger la france
le 21 avril avec moi fait peser une
tranche alternative à la politique
socialiste à construire une nouvelle
france une france qui donne à chacun sa
chance une france qui vit avec son temps
[Musique]
on est quand même au 21e siècle